-Oh, it's so good to be here
I'm very anxious.
And I was walking down the
street the other day,
and this girl was walking in
front of me.
And she was on the phone, and
listened to her conversation
And it was literally like,
"Oh, my God.
I was on Instagram
and I posted this post.
And I look so good.
Like, I look so good,
I look so pretty,
and, like, nobody commented.
Nobody. Nobody commented, like
Julie, Amy, Melissa.
Nobody commented.
I was, like, freaking out.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
...Instagram."
So I tapped her on the shoulde
and I said,
"I've been following you!"
And she ran away. She ran away
'Cause I get depressed, too.
You know,
I'm normally in dark colors.
My friend said to me
the other day,
"Why do you always wear black?
And I'm like, "Oh, 'cause I feel
great about my body
and I'm filled with hope."
I mean, I have a master's
in social work,
and now I'm a traveling clown.
I literally travel around
and tell jokes.
It's crazy.
I'm trying to take care
of myself,
so I downloaded this app where
you count your calories.
The problem is -- I lie on it.
How sick is that?
I lie on my own app.
That is sick.
Like, the other day, I had three
bagels, a roast, and a pie
and I wrote down
one baby carrot.
Like, "It's okay, Jessica.
You really are talented.
You are, and you need to top
putting yourself down.
You deserve success.
It's all going to be okay.
You need to stop eating
salads in public.
You're not fooling anyone.
You know, oatmeal is healthy
unless you add
6 cups of brown sugar.
Then it becomes pie.
You had a miniature pie
for breakfast
and told three people
you had oatmeal.
You're a liar."
Okay, so, my mother's
a therapist.
My mother is a therapist
and she saw clients
in the basement my whole life.
This is totally true.
So I had to be quiet every day
She'd say things like,
"Susan's coming,
and she's having
a really hard time,
so I'm gonna need you
to be quiet.
Take off your shoes.
No running around.
No flushing the toilet.
No opening chips.
Susan's in turmoil."
I'm like, "Well,
I just ate six pizzas
and beheaded my Barbies,
but good luck to Susan."
The Roots are laughing.
So, I -- That's all I care about
is that The Roots are laughing
So, I do a lot of shows in
Florida for very old people.
Most of them are 80, 90.
Some have passed.
And I have to make them laugh,
and they have all the same face,
even when they're saying
something positive.
"It's gorgeous outside.
Look at this weather.
The sun is out.
The test came back negative.
I'm gonna live."
They talk during the whole show,
because they can't stop --
And they talk loud
'cause they're deaf.
This is totally true.
So I'll be in
the middle of my act
and I'll hear them having
whole conversation like,
"Did she just say she's
from New Jersey?"
"I think she did say
she's from New Jersey."
"What part of New Jersey?
Do you think she knows
the Eisensteins?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
They sound like cats
being assaulted.
Just "Aaaaah!
Aaaah! Bingo!"
"You knew that tag line
wasn't gonna work,
and you did it anyway.
Don't sabotage yourself.
You deserve success.
It's all gonna be okay.
You just ate a bag of chip
and told yourself it was
a serving of corn."
You know, I went to
visit my grandmother,
and all these old women si
around and play cards,
and they all sound like
little bees when they talk
They hunch over.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
"Salmon."
So I go to find her,
and she's not there.
And I go up to her
friend Rona and I said,
"Rona, do you know where m
grandmother is?"
And she goes,
"I don't know, darling,
but I'll let her know
you were looking for her.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
...trust fund."
So, I walk away and I hear her
yell out -- unbelievable -
"That's Bea Farbman's
granddaughter.
She's a lesbian magician."
You guys are great.
Thank you so much.
♪♪♪♪
Thank you.
-"Jessica Kirson: Talking
to Myself"
premieres December 6th
on Comedy Central.